[Musique]
comprendre le truc c'est le dernier jour
aujourd'hui c'est pas si on va bien
comme ça je me suis dit on est bien là
ouailles derniers jours de kung fu
aujourd'hui aweys étaient plutôt cool
il y avait des choses vraiment ils
prennent intéressante mais malgré tout
je reste un petit peu dubitatif alors
faut que je vous explique de quoi je
vais vous parler aux autres
[Musique]
je
qualcomm fait les processeurs des
standards goal j'en ai déjà parlé dans
ma vidéo d'avant comme fait également
des processeurs pour ordinateur vous
avez est ce qu'on appelle et always
connected pc always own et a notamment
la puce 8c hic c'est que plutôt sur le
haut de gamme qui vous permet d'avoir un
pc de pouvoir ouvrir il allumé pour
refermer vous tenez pas comme un
ordinateur classique qui peut durer
plusieurs jours d'autonomie vous allez
pouvoir connecter à la 5g enfin ce
qu'est vraiment cool en faisant toujours
d'une puce milieu de gamme depuis
d'entretien pour héberger tout ça donc
ça c'est intéressant dans des jarres
faille on en reparlera plus tard le
redis je veux pas d'un truc que je
voudrais de ce qu'ils appellent civique
ça
[Musique]
lexar ça regroupe la vère donc la
réalité virtuelle et la r est la réalité
augmentée va tous ses deux mandats qui
sera le trou qui peuvent se mélanger ou
pas et ça donne l'icsa maintenant la
question c'est est-ce que l'iq ça a
vraiment un avenir est ce que dit que ça
peut marcher
est-ce que lexar à sa place ou pas vous
avez déjà une opinion là-dessus
gouverneur qui a commenté moi je sais
pas je sais pas je suis un peu dubitatif
je trouve que la promesse faite ça bouge
la table bouge un peu
la promesse faite par hectare est
vachement intéressante parce que en fait
au delà de l'arrêté virtuel où on
connaît vraiment les usages de gaming
nous emmener sur un autre usage cet été
je vous en mets au festival art le futur
de réalité virtuelle de la famille de
voir des finances a permis d'avoir une
autre approche saas intéressant mais si
on mélange notamment la réalité
augmentée et la réalité virtuelle à des
choses cool alors pas de nouvelle bonne
nouvelle en toi tu disparais comme ça et
on revend revenir un jour mais c'est pas
grave parce que j'ai travaillé comme ac
écossais en même temps je trouvais que
c'était énorme j'ai dit c'est ne pas
manger pendant vingt-quatre hier soir il
a pas moche elle est partie pendant
vingt quatre ans je n'ai pas mangé parce
qu'elle trouve énorme
vous avez des origines du monde j'ai
peur que l'avion ne décolle pas d'avoir
un gros qu on a pas mal travaillé ou de
faire semblant de travailler tard est
toutefois qu'on voit pas ce que ça
attends attends je me remets en place ce
hangar douleur gardons en regarnissant
garde la main
meiway regarde pas l'écran ne regarde
pas l'écran non je regarde la regarde là
bas on va et toi ils passent le bac
[Musique]
quand un mode plus haut de trois mois je
bosse vraiment mais c'est des mecs qui
ont des passions qui fait juste pour
travailler mes félicitations retourner
sur l'île on est sur deux soldats
meurent one c'était ma technique
rappelle ma propre et ibos à l'hôpital
médian à ses côtés en mode analyse
économique de marché par les toulousains
intéresse pas mais c'est son complice 30
ans qui se rend chez balmain dit si vous
connaissez un banc commentaires et si
vous lisez bien les lire ailleurs c'est
très bien mais il faut vraiment se dire
que en fait on va imaginer mais pas en
passant par un ordinateur
vous n'avez pas votre câble aux
ordinateurs ou c'est la carte graphique
de votre ordinateur qui fait taf
on n'est pas là dessus on est vraiment
sur des casques indépendant comme le
plus juste ouest que je vous ai présenté
il ya quelques temps qui repose sur le
sens dragonne 835 là on est sur des
nouvelles puces une fois depuis que tu
as porté par qualcomm c'est la xr2 qui
est 5g truc vraiment cool que vous avez
un casque qui autonome vous le relier à
votre smartphone dans 5 g vous êtes
poule vous connecter pas tout vous
voulez avoir de la réalité augmentée
erreur de la vère de façon beaucoup plus
simple sans câble façon portative grâce
à votre smartphone et ça c'est vraiment
ultra couleurs ya des visages de dingue
il ya des usages pour tous pouvait être
professionnels notamment pour la santé
un médecin un poids avant de la réalité
augmentée pour une intéresse pas
vraiment il sera intéressant s'il ya
dans le support pourquoi pas ça peut
être aussi intéressant pour l'entretien
pour des centrales nucléaires ya pas mal
de choses comme ça pour de la mécanique
pour beaucoup beaucoup de points de
poudenas professionnels
on a pour le rite à gaza qui sont aussi
très intéressante il ya côté
divertissement mais on veut on peut lire
beaucoup plus loin images les présents
vous avec votre smartphone ou de
connecter votre casque de réalité
augmentée mieux bavarde des lunettes
l'hyper transparent vous avez les mains
libres
et là vous allez à la réalité augmentée
vous arrivez vous à y voir un match eh
bien imaginez ce n'est pas une action
qui se passe d'avoir le replay pas
toutes les statistiques de but du joueur
où il ya voir sur l'écran je ne sais où
il ya vous avez directement dans vos
lunettes ça peut être cool de c'est
intéressant dans un coin sympa
il ya pas mal visage maintenant la
question qu'on se pose c'est est-ce que
ces prêts aujourd'hui ou non pas lui
mais rien
non tu peux te présenter déjà dans un
premier temps savoir qu est ce que tu
fais je m'appelle même genre je viens
podcast qui s'appelle mobiletag phocas à
montech podcast points comme bloqués à
sebha c'est en anglais et je suis base
de deux états unis et j'ai
principalement le podcast avec un
inquiète channel youtube aussi je vous
sens que tu as pensé quoi d'axa de style
ans on dit aujourd'hui prête à dijon est
reçue à coude avec qualcomm le truc sur
l'icc serre c'est que c'est toujours la
même chose ça fait dix ans qu'ils
montent
luxair et 7 de 10 ans qu'on n'a pas
vraiment encore de l'ex de lixheim ouais
ça veut dire avec la mer
la nr la r tout mélanger ensemble c'est
sûr je veux pas dire ça de façon candide
négative mais bien sûr les applications
de business sont âgées valides mais
c'est pas vraiment encore commencé à
venir vers le consommateur
c'est grand public qui va dire on n'est
pas encore fait voilà et je pense pour
lui il ya eu des exemples de bons
exemples comme occulte go aucune
prouesse mes yeux rouleau lenge divisa
la toile comme maintenant ici mais c'est
pas vraiment encore trop répandue quoi
c'est ça le problème et je pense qu'il
va y avoir un moment un clipping pointe
on dit en anglais il ça va vraiment
commencer à être intéressant pour les
consommateurs
c'est ça qui m'intéresse mais chaque
année je vois l'évolution de qualcomm et
ça c'est une très bonne évolution je
dire il faut que quelqu'un fasse ce
travail mais je pense que on n'est pas
encore au point où les consommateurs
vont pouvoir vraiment s'exciter à ce
niveau là je crois que l'arrivée de la
5g va permettre de faire évoluer ça va
aider à mon avis mais le problème c'est
l'apparence et le fera de ces produits
les gens écoutent qui veulent pas moi je
dis que je mets un un truc vert sur ma
tête
au bout de quinze minutes j'ai fini
c'est ça rien à voir la qualité de la
vidéo c'est parce que c'est trop lourd
je sus et pas confortable et je pense
que les gens ça l'est
ça les emmerde quoi alors ah si leurs
résultats avec une paire de lunettes
comme ça qu'ils deviennent opaques après
que jean tissier là je restais murray
est bien mon avis de faire seulement je
pense que le vert c'est vraiment une
étape vers le ar et on aère c'est
l'ultime que tu couvres ses yeux l'état
du vr
donc clic on peut avoir des lunettes
comme ça qu'ils sont complètement
indépendantes qui se connecte sur 5 g
sarah peut-être a duré redevenir un peu
plus viable
diable bon à mon avis apple va peut-être
nous surprend un jour avec quelque chose
comme ça ils sont très forts à ça ils
vont suivre la chose et puis vont nous
faire quelque chose de vraiment
spectaculaire
ou peut-être quelqu'un d'autre va
devenir centre selon sais pas mais à mon
avis avant que ça arrive ça c'est très
risqué on dit en anglais n'ont que la
peau vraiment d'avenir le futur bravo et
je pas méchante verres.com parce que je
pense qu'il faut que pouvez-vous faire
cette recherche vous faire ce travail
mais cinq années ils mettent ça sur ap
des salles un peu trop et bien peu trop
spectacle là parce que je pense que
c'est vraiment pas pris en compte
je me pose beaucoup qu'ils sont là
dessus parce que je trouve que le seul
principe c'est hyper intéressant la
province est vraiment génial le fait
qu'on ait une avancée technologique de
l'appart qualcomm avec cette nouvelle
puce ça mon petit se passe des choses
sans doute qu'il ya une avancée ce un
nom qu'on peut faire quelque chose on va
pouvoir avoir une qualité qui va être
vraiment augmenter l'autonomie qui va
être augmenté et surtout c'est le truc
qu'on reproche vraiment notamment à la
réalité virtuelle c'est l'effet gris la
peau qu'on va vraiment monter
significativement qualité paille de la
faillite
ce qu'on fait avec cette puce qui dit
l'avoir c'est effectivement de la vidéo
c'est d'avoir de lo'jo d'avoir la
collectivité sur la toile et dans le
mouvement dans l'espace
ça va aussi pouvoir suivre vos yeux
c'est plus sympa d'avoir encore plus de
vitesse d'avoir plus d'autonomie
ce toutefois remonter jusqu'à huit cas à
60 images par seconde ou alors en cas de
cassure des images par seconde ça évite
cet effet geri ça permet d'avoir une
meilleure qualité beaucoup plus immersif
moi je ne sais pas si vous jouez mieux
appliquer envers moi c'était déranger et
ce qui me dérange encore parfois c'est
cet effet un peu de gris le fait de pas
voir un champ de vision hyper large avec
cette idéologie plus fort plus de
capacités de calcul
j'arrive vraiment pas savoir si au final
est ce que le consommateur est prêt je
sais que du côté professionnel il ya
plein d'usagé à ce débat mais du côté
grand public
je sais pas bonjour chez hubert guez
chez cofondateur du berguille lancé un
site tech basé à san francisco en
californie continue et san francisco
je viens sans france et hbos alors du
mois on a eu à constater notamment sur
la ixe art qu'est ce que tu obtiens toi
qu'est ce qui te plaît plus là dedans
moi j'adore le concept que le nouveau
raid sciatique ça en fait ils vont s
être utilisé pour les arts et le
le vieil air et en fait c'est vachement
pratique parce que au bureau j'ai des
recettes de toutes sortes
ouais et j'aimerais bien un peu
centraliser tout ça et c'est vrai qu'il
ya des moments où on voudrait peut-être
faire du ixe art par exemple pour
réparer quelque chose et un autre moment
peut jouer avec le même genre jet set en
étant complètement en immersion
ouais et ça pour moi c'est un gros dunk
en avant c'est le fait tout unifié en
fait oui quelque part c'est un peu
l'aboutissement de tous ces chemins une
bande
x reality en quelque chose qui va
devenir peut-être plus stable tu penses
que toile la réalité augmentée la 5g
switchers qui va emmener la réalité
augmentée plus loin c'est la
démocratiser déjà tu arrives d'enlever
les câbles c'est quelque chose qui
démocratise automatiquement parce que
c'est quand même vachement
embêtant de devoir avoir le pc de tous
connectés et ça ça limite vachement
mouvement et en plus on sait que à
partir du moment ça bien mobile ça
devenir moins chers et forcément ça va
se démocratiser way
c'est juste trop pratique pour ignorer
je trouve ça vraiment génial parce que
ça montre une vision de la société à
l'avenir alors c'était qui s'enferme
bonjour tous avec le casque de réalité
virtuelle mort parle pas mais l'idée
vous est comme un peu ce qu'on avec les
google dance
il ya quelques années mais si on passe
un petit peu côté intrusif dans la vie
privée le fait d'avoir des informations
augmente et le fait par exemple de ce
bail dans la rue et d'avoir son google
maps qui vous dit on à droite on à
gauche quand vous êtes touristes ça
c'était le bâtiment vous pouvez en plus
l'audio qui vous explique imaginez vous
allez dans un musée par l'angola et vos
lunettes et bien vous avez tous des
informations sur les tableaux fin c'est
un vrai sens c'est vraiment une très
intéressant et j'ai l'impression qu'on
n'y est pas encore je sais pas est ce
que ça pourrait vous intéresser vous est
ce que vous pourriez vous projetez
entend consommateurs à l'avenir d'avoir
des lunettes
vous pourriez utiliser pour campagne
déserte correcteurs mais sont à pointer
avec de la réalité augmentée est ce que
vous pourriez vous projeter là dedans
moi je suis hyper enthousiaste c'est pas
pour maintenant c'est pas pour 2020
c'est le début on commence à
entrapercevoir d'abord tout ce qui va
être dit ou vit ensuite le bitoux s'y
met tous à ypres intéresse monsieur ppe
aurélien en ce film inception de youtube
heures et un journaliste ils font là le
seul mais le djing peut cacher derrière
lui ah c'est vrai en plus ça ferait ça
va but et écoute ça va je suis très très
content sa troisième journée
ouais donc je raconte après une crue
fortement à la lagune et angola comme
d'hab lassé de la 3e journée je crois
que on a fait le tour du sujet est une
icône et wassila x rvr à rds alors ça
c'est franchement franchement je
l'aixplorer tout ça mais c'est pas le
truc sur lequel je mise à fond dans tout
ce que je fais dans ma carrière
professionnelle
j'ai eu beaucoup de gens qui m'en
parlait un peu partout mais j'ai du mal
à concevoir un monde comme ils ont dit
tout à l'heure où il y aurait des
lunettes qui remplacerait à la fois les
cantons smartphone à la fois une salle
de cinéma à la fin d'un téléviseur à la
fin d' écran de pc pour moi ça me paraît
hallucinant mais je peux me tromper
tu peux taper mon vieux j'en sais rien
quand même et moi j'estime que tu as
quand même certains trucs on aura
toujours besoin parce que la salle de
ciné langueur j'imagine pas après que
vous avez plus à lui signer ses maxis et
ses lunettes de verges du mal avec cette
voie elle l'idée pas d'aller voir un
concert où aller voir un match ce que tu
veux les voir il tente et ouais ça peut
être pas mal sur certaines phases
certaines actions ça tout le temps mais
là pas marrant ça ça peut être sympa moi
je vois plus sur le sport
on ne voit pas toujours les trucs
inscrits comment il en train de regarder
un dans un stade voir les joueurs des
joueurs toi pas grave et voir les trucs
qui était ce mec tu peux la voir comme
ça aurait été augmentés ça j'y crois et
panasonic avait présenté un truc à las
vegas là dessus il ya deux ans il met
beaucoup plus sûr en effet n'aurait été
augmenté dans les stades et tous les
trucs sportif athlétisme jeux olympiques
et aux ça j'y crois mais la cour le
conseil lui-même où tu voi le mec est en
train de chanter ou un groupe je pense
que ça a plutôt envie de participer que
d'avoir le retour ici et ben ouais je
vous passe cas aux premiers rangs en
mettant en liaison avec kaka au premier
rang tu vas tomber l'itinérance en 2g
voilà les faits ce qui a donc tu vois
même plus le concert tu voi le mec et de
premier rang qui te renvoie le signal du
smartphone
là j'ai un peu de mal avec ça mais quand
elle peut taper mon vieux mais l'avenir
dira mais pour le concert musical je
pense que c'est peut-être pas la
solution mais pour les stades pour le
sport voit ça il ya quelques mois ils
s'amusaient neymar restaurants des
salles du cinéma bordel merci monsieur
c'est beau quand on est vraiment quelque
chose que vous en pensez en bons
commentaires est ce que vous pourriez
vous nous projeter là dedans est ce que
vous voyez visage qu'est-ce que vous
imagineriez comme visage
et puis est ce que ça pourrait voter
simplement oui ou non mark et moi tout
ça en bas on continue à parler de teck
on se retrouve demain probablement
demain il ya plein de choses avec le
voyage à hawaï j'ai pas pu peser tous
les jours car un petit peu compliqué
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de combos coup
deux affaires donc voilà moment c'est un
peu plus dur mais on va repartir sur une
vidéo par jour extrêmement rapidement
lorsque vous embrasse vous donne
rendez-vous à l'est presque demain on
verra
je vous embrasse tous